[Musique]
bonsoir le journal de tv soixante dix
huit pour un condensé d'actualité locale
bienvenue dans cette édition du mercredi
25 novembre voici les titres
c'est l'une des annonces ford emmanuel
macron dans son allocution d'hier les
commerces non essentiels pourront
rouvrir et ce malgré la poursuite du
confinement quelles réactions auprès des
acteurs locaux reportage à montigny le
bretonneux 25 novembre date de la
journée internationale pour
l'élimination de la violence à l'égard
des femmes à cette occasion présentation
d'une initiative de la police nationale
des yvelines à qr code pour que les
victimes obtiennent des informations
utiles et puis invité hélène de poncey
vice président de l'union nationale des
familles de féminicide enfin avec le
confinement c'est le monde étudiant qui
est impacté les restaurants et
résidences universitaires continuent
malgré tout leurs activités rencontre
également avec un jeune colombien venu
étudier à l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines qui vit forcément
une période particulière l'allocution
était très attendue emmanuel macron
s'est exprimé hier pendant environ 30
minutes le président de la république a
précisé les prochaines étapes et du
confinement qui sera levé
progressivement trois étapes à retenir
est la première dès ce samedi avec la
réouverture des commerces dits non
essentiels qui se fera cependant avec un
protocole renforcé autorisation des
offices religieux qui pourront se faire
avec une jauge maximale de 30 personnes
présentes dans les édifices et puis pour
vos promenades et footing dès samedi
vous aurez la possibilité de les faire
pendant trois heures et dans un rayon de
20 km autour de votre domicile
l'attestation et de déplacements restent
cependant obligatoire
étape 2 à partir du 15 décembre si les
contaminations au co vite 19 repasse
sous la barre des 5000 par jour le
confinement sera levé remplacé par un
couvre-feu qui se fera donc avec un
une étendue de 21h à 7h du matin seule
exception les soirs des 24 et 31
décembre où la circulation pourra se
faire librement pour les fêtes de fin
d'année et si la situation sanitaire le
père mais les cinémas théâtres et musées
pourront également rouvrir avec un
protocole strict un système d'horodatage
pourra permettre des représentations en
fin de journée a précisé le président de
la république et dernière étape si tous
les objectifs épidémiques sont remplies
enfin les restaurants et des salles de
sport pourront de nouveau levé le rideau
tout comme les lycées en 100% présentiel
ainsi que les universités deux semaines
plus tard emmanuel macron a par ailleurs
dit qu'une campagne de vaccination
pourrait d'ores et déjà débuté fin
décembre voire début janvier
toutes ces annonces seront à détailler
demain jeudi par un point fait par le
premier ministre jean castex et par le
gouvernement vous l'entendiez les
commerces dits non essentiels vont
pouvoir ouvrir dès samedi et ce après un
mois de fermeture une délivrance pour
les principaux intéressés es les
réactions dans ce reportage à montigny
le bretonneux de célia gars de son go
les portes sont encore close mais dans
cette boutique de l'espace saint quentin
à montigny le bretonneux
les vendeuses se prépare à la
réouverture de leurs magasins on a été
très content de l'annnonce du président
parce qu'on avait vraiment très envie
d'ouvrir le magasin on a reçu toute la
marchandise toute l'année la nouvelle
collection toutes les idées cadeaux de
noël on a préparé la vitrine mannequins
sont habillés donc on a très hâte mais
la réouverture des boutiques ne va pas
sans un protocole sanitaires très
strictes
le président de la république dans son
allocution télévisée a décrété la règle
des huit mètres carrés par personne
contre 4 avant leur confinement
on est limité à 30 clients maximum dans
l'enceinte du magasin
donc on sera bien attention vu que l'on
a toujours quelqu'un à l'accueil du
magasin
on fera bien attention pour filtrer le
maximum de clients pour éviter d'avoir
trop de monde car la période de noël est
la plus importante pour les commerçants
dans la librairie le pavé du canal le
mois de novembre et décembre représente
25% du chiffre d'affaires de l'année
tous les samedis on les compte forcément
donc même juste un week-end avant un
samedi c'est pas c'est pas neutre non
plus sur notre chiffre d'affaires donc
et c'est une très très bonne chose que
ça ou dès le 28 novembre cinquante
personnes maxi
mam pourront rentrer dans la librairie
en même temps ce qui équivaut à 12
mètres carrés par client on va compter
les personnes qui vont rentrer et on va
donc compter aussi des personnes qui
vont sortir on va se protéger de moussy
avec des périmètres de sécurité rendez
pyramide sanitaire autour de nos
accueils et tout ce qui à tous les
points de caisse aussi il va falloir
qu'on fasse des des files d'attentes qui
soit conforme aux contraintes mais les
clients seront ils au rendez vous le
responsable de la librairie y croire je
pense que va y avoir du monde mais parce
qu'il ya une forte attente aussi de la
part des clients des lecteurs et puis
des cadeaux de noël vont commencer à se
préparer maintenant
donc oui je pense qu'il va y avoir un
peu de monde samedi m il est 19 salariés
seront en tout cas sur le pont dès
samedi 28 novembre matin tous les
commerces devront fermer leurs portes à
21h les cinémas théâtres et musées
pourront rouvrir le 15 décembre les
restaurants et les salles de sport le 20
janvier
si la situation sanitaire le terme et
dans son discours emmanuel macron a fixé
aussi un objectif mieux isoler les cas
positifs avec des tests qui seront
toujours au coeur de la stratégie de
déconfinement tests pcr dont les
résultats devront être connues maximum
en 24 heures a fixé comme objectif le
président et puis aussi les tests et
antigénique antigénique inquiet à
livrent leur verdict en 30 minutes après
une première opération septembre à
destination des entreprises
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines renouvelle ses journées de
dépistage pour cette fois ci tous les
habitants ce sera les 1er et 2 décembre
au vélodrome national situé à montigny
le bretonneux et 2000 tests anti génie
qui seront réalisés gratuitement l'accès
se fait sur rendez vous auprès de
l'application d'octo libre chaque année
en france environ 220 mille femmes sont
victimes de violences conjugales 146
sont mortes l'an passé sous les coups de
leur compagnon ou ex conjoint ce 25
novembre c'est la journée internationale
pour l'élimination de la violence à
l'égard des femmes dans le contexte
particulier du confinement qui a fait
exploser le phénomène afin de l'endiguer
la police nationale des yvelines est à
l'origine d'une initiative qui vient
d'être lancée celle d'un qr codes que
les victimes peuvent scanner pour
obtenir des informations utiles
explications dans cette interview menée
par eléonore sinoquet avec la major
fabienne boulard est une petite banque
qui se présente comme ça où il ya juste
un qr code qui est imprimé dessus de
manière à ce que les policiers qui
interviennent au domicile des victimes
d'éventuelles victimes puissent
présenter puis données discrètement
surtout cette petite cape portait la
victime lorsque les policiers quittent
le domicile soit avec l'individu si
l'auteur des faits c'est une
interpellation soit si les parties
soient enfin peu importe pour que la
victime docu savoir toutes les
coordonnées nécessaires à son
accompagnement sans même et son
accompagnement en forme nos collègues à
l'accueil
et puis à la prise en charge dont
notamment leur explique ce qu'est
l'emprise mentale le stress post
traumatique pourquoi une victime n'est
pas forcément quoi on pourrait
l'imaginer mais il nous manque un petit
un petit maillon dans la chaîne
c'est-à-dire que quand les policiers
interviennent au domicile jeux vidéo ont
parce que j'en fais partie on est
souvent les seuls à pouvoir entrer au
domicile quand la famille le plus
souhaité entre guillemets séquestré une
fois entre guillemets d'ailleurs par son
parent samcon points et on est les seuls
à avoir ce contact là avec la victime
dans un premier temps on a mis les
appels en cas d'urgence le 17
le fait d'aller déposer plainte
le fait qu'il y ait deux plateformes à
disposition des victimes et ensuite on a
mis des contacts plus locaux propres
yvelines avec cinq associations des
yvelines qui sont clairement non mais
clairement ciblé et qui peuvent être le
contacter par la victime ça peut
permettre de libérer la parole
donc si c'est une voisine par exemple
qui dénonce ça peut nous permettre
d'ouvrir une enquête
alors évidemment une enquête n'est pas
d'initiative des policiers il faut
qu'elle soit comme on pourrait dire a
dicté par la justice entre guillemets
mais ça peut permettre de prendre des
contacts et puis d'aller d'aller au
contact de la victime qui osera près pas
faire le premier pas vous savez si on
arrive à toucher une ou deux victimes et
qu on la sauve entre guillemets et pour
continuer à parler de ce sujet et même
de pons est avec moi plateau bons soirs
comme ça où est la cofondatrice la vice
présidente d'une association l'union
nationale des familles de féminicide on
va parler dans un instant de cette
association fondée en 2019 qui soutient
les familles et qui fait aussi de la
prévention de la sensibilisation déjà
cette journée du 25 novembre intervient
aussi je le disais dans les titres dans
un contexte particulier celui du
confinement qui peut être chaotique pour
les femmes victimes de violences
conjugales depuis mars dernier
ce chiffre le signalement des violences
conjugales ont augmenté de 42%
c'est un chiffre du ministère de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
est ce que c'est une période c'est pas
du confinement qui est qui vous inquiète
particulièrement
c'est une peine qui nous inquiète pour
les violences parce que on a vu les
chiffres des féminicides wc mais on a vu
les chiffres des violences déclarées
augmentent et en fait quand vous êtes
confiné avec votre bourreau vous avez
juste aucune échappée aucun échappatoire
vous pouvez pas aller au bureau vous
pouvez pas aller à l'école donc vous
êtes vraiment exposés à beaucoup de
violence
en revanche les chiffres des féminicides
eux on les a vu diminuer et il faut pas
s'en féliciter trop vite parce que le
fait que les femmes ne partent plus
c'est un facteur déclenchant qui n'a
plus lieu elles ne peuvent pas partir
donc on les tue pas le 25 novembre
on est aussi un an tout juste après la
fin du grenelle sur les violences
conjugales qui avait été lancé par le
gouvernement souvient des mesures phares
qui en avait découlé
les dépôts de plaintes notamment à
l'hôpital qui sont possibles la mise en
place de procureurs référence sur la
question les bracelets électroniques
aussi anti-rapprochement le gouvernement
faisait d'ailleurs aujourd'hui le bilan
des mesures lancées a indiqué le
gouvernement que 28 mesures sur les 46
qui va qui avait été qui avait découlé
de ce grenelle ont déjà été déployés
pour autant plusieurs associations
féministes se mobiliser aujourd'hui pour
demander plus de moyens un budget
notamment d'un milliard d'euros pour
lutter contre les violences conjugales
est ce que les choses progressent ou
exclut toutefois aller plus loin d'après
vous pour mes jambes oui oui c'est à
dire que les choses progressent et que
2019 c'est une année qui a vu
effectivement le terme féminicide et le
derby violence conjugale à la une de
tous les journaux pendant toute la durée
de l'année que des bonbonnes mesures ont
été annoncées que quelques-unes d'entre
elles ont commencé à être appliquée mais
qu'elles ne vont pas assez loin et qu'il
faut aller un peu plus vite pour les
déployer 2019 c'est donc l'année du
grenelle des violences conjugales c'est
aussi une année
tristement record pour les féminicides
il ya eu 146 féminicide qui ont été
perpétrés en france c'est l'année où a
été fondée injustement votre association
l'union nationale des familles de
féminicide hélène de poncey vous avez
perdu votre soeur marie alice l'an passé
qui a été assassinée par son ex-conjoint
c'est ce drame qui vous a poussé à vous
joindre avec d'autres fondatrice
justement pour pour fonder cette
association absolument ma soeur a été
assassiné par son réalité son conjoint
qu'elle quittait et on se retrouve quand
une chose comme ça
arrivent dans votre famille totalement
isolé et complètement démunis dans un
désarroi total est la seule le seul
salut ça a été de rencontrer d'autres
familles qui avaient vécu la même chose
et qui en partageant en échangeant nous
en nous ont permis de retrouver la force
et l'envié d'avancer de me battre pour
faire en sorte que cette cette mort
affreuse puisse sauver d'autres vies
ce que vous disiez chesneau conforte
cette ut accus dans un article vous
parliez justement de ces familles qui
ont vécu et fémicide et le fait qu'elle
se retrouve totalement seule livrée à
elle même il ya des procédures
judiciaires il ya l'aspect psychologique
et ça aujourd'hui a pas assez il ya pas
assez de l'accompagnement ça ça fait
partie des choses qui ont été oubliés
par le grenelle c'est à dire que les
familles de victimes aujourd'hui ne se
voient offrir aucun accompagnement
support psychologique après le meurtre
intrafamiliales il ya c'est un choc post
traumatique énorme qui est impossible de
surmonter sans se faire accompagner pour
le choix de leurs avocats ne sont pas
guidés elles ne savent pas qu'elles ont
droit à l'aide juridictionnelle sans
condition de ressources
elle se retrouve à être défendus par des
avocats qui ne connaissent pas
nécessairement les violences conjugales
est tout simplement d'un point de vue
social et financier souvent elles se
retrouvent dans la plus grande solitude
pour effectuer leurs démarches liées
aussi un problème pour vous c'est la
prise en charge des enfants vous l'a
jugée chaotique
aujourd'hui absolument chaotique parce
que les enfants aujourd'hui qui se
retrouve orphelin de mère et parfois
aussi de pair ils sont placés sans aucun
recul sur les situations dans le
département de la seine saint denis où
ils ont mis en place un protocole
féminicide les enfants sont mis dans un
cadre
préservé qui permet à tout le monde de
réfléchir calmement à la fois les
familles les psys les différentes
juridictions pour savoir ce qui est le
mieux pour l'enfant l'enfant qui se
retrouvent dans la famille des parents
du duc du parent meurtrier pour lui
c'est un enfant qui risque d'être
exposés à une minimisation de la gravité
de l'acte commis par le père et ça c'est
extrêmement toxique et c'est des choses
qui s'ancre très profondément dans leur
psychisme et qui peuvent faire 2 soit
deux futures victimes soit de feature
violent et on veut absolument éviter ça
on veut absolument préserver les enfants
de ce2 de ce choc
donc il ya un accompagnement et ce qui
est aussi un rôle justement de
sensibilisation notamment peut être
auprès des pouvoirs publics sur les
choses qui manquent aujourd'hui oui
alors notre notre axe de travail
d'accompagnement des familles est
complété par un axe de travail
prévention et dans cet acte de
prévention
on travaille sur deux choses à la fois
la sensibilisation des médias à faire en
sorte que comme vous ce soir vous vous
nous vous vous relayer notre parole est
aussi un rôle de plaidoyer auprès du
gouvernement auprès des institutions
publiques de façon à ce que les
remontées que nous nous avons des
familles
puissent être prises en compte que la
loi puisse évoluer que de nouvelles
mesures puissent être prises et que et
que ces familles se retrouvent enfin
soutenu une dernière question on l'a dit
ça fait un an que votre association
existe l'idée en 2021 c'est d'abord un
maillage un peu plus territoriale être
plus présent au travers des régions de
france
oui alors c'est déjà commencé
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui on a
commencé à nouer des partenariats avec
des associations qui sont présentes sur
la plupart des territoires de france
ce que nous cherchons à faire c'est
obtenir des subventions et effectuer des
levées de fonds de façon à ce que nous
puissions nous appuyer sur des
professionnels rémunérés on travaille
beaucoup avec l'aide de bénévoles très
généreux de leur temps mais on a besoin
de toi retravailler avec des
professionnels que nous rémunérons pour
pouvoir assurer prendre le relais de ce
que nous faisons déjà auprès des
familles nous épauler et épauler ces
familles et toutes les informations sur
votre association sur le site 1 qui
s'affiche actuellement en bas de l'écran
merci hélène de ponça d'être mais si le
vice président de l'union nationale des
familles de féminicide je précise
d'ailleurs que votre association est
intervenu dans l'émission ils font
bouger les lignes qui a été diffusé hier
mardi sur france 5 une émission inquiet
disponibles bien sûr en replay
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également il a été
reconduit à la tête de l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
alain buis a été réélu hier mardi lors
du conseil d'administration de l'ubs est
est-ce qu son mandat débutera le 1er
décembre pour quatre ans il s'agira du
deuxième pour lui qui avait succédé à
didier guillemot démissionnaire en 2017
pour raisons de santé
un second mandat pour emmener la
communauté vers l'avenir construire et
parachevait la nouvelle université paris
saclay 2025 a commenté alain buis après
son élection à l'université justement le
crous centre régional des oeuvres
universitaires et scolaires a dû
s'adapter avec ce deuxième confinement
des aides pour les locataires des
résidences étudiantes ou encore la vente
à emporter pour les restaurants
universitaires ont été remises en place
elle et précision dans ce sujet de
bixente n'a rien senti steban et de
patrick jacques de dixmude
avec environ 200 mille étudiants sur son
territoire l'académie de versailles et
l'une des plus importantes de france
sont cros a dû s'adapter une nouvelle
fois face aux deuxièmes confinement pour
subvenir aux besoins des étudiants
le restaurant du crous de guyancourt est
resté ouvert en vente à emporter avec
des repas à 1 euro pour les boursiers je
trouve ça très intéressant ça m'arrange
manquant même beaucoup puisque moi
j'habite au très loin donc hall était de
préparer chez moi et les venir parce que
moi je travaille à l'abbaye parce que
chez moi y'a pas de connexion là
jusqu'au mis en route en fait ce qu'on
avait déjà mis en place au soleil ça a
été toute simple et aura-t-il puisque
quand l'europe au film en a été annoncée
le jeudi dès le lundi nous étions en
capacité de remettre en route cette
vente à emporter une adaptation rapide
mais nécessaire contrairement aux
premiers confinement l'année
universitaire est encore longue
les étudiants étrangers ou de province
ne sont pas rentrés chez eux
j'avoue beaucoup plus d'étudiants qui
viennent se restaurer
lors de ce concours finement par rapport
au premier nous faisons at e3 50 repas
par jour les étudiants se présente entre
11h30 et 13h30
ils peuvent bénéficier de repas ce
composant
donc d'un sachet qui contient une entrée
un plat chaud à consommer immédiatement
rien des faits outre les restaurants les
résidences étudiantes sont encore
occupés un suivi régulier est effectué
par les agents d'accueil pour déceler
les jeunes en difficulté et mettre en
place des aides financières ou
psychologique
ainsi tout seul dans un studio 20 mètres
carrés c'est quand même pas forcément
facile tout le temps en fait ils ont un
numéro qui peuvent appeler prendre
rendez vous et il ya des créneaux qui
leur sont attribuées pour pouvoir
échanger avec un psychologue sur les
difficultés qu'ils peuvent rencontrer
les animations culturelles en
vidéoconférence sont aussi été maintenue
parmi les 132 résidents du bâtiment
vauban de guyancourt deux tiers sont
restés sur place
c'est bien plus que lors du premier
confinement et comme lors du premier
confinement à destination des étudiants
le secours populaire des yvelines
organise des distributions de sacs
alimentaires et de produits de première
nécessité ce mercredi de distribution
avait lieu au pied des résidences la
marque et cassante est à elancourt on
écoute la secrétaire départementale des
yvelines au micro d'eléonore sinoquet
avec le crous on a démarré un
partenariat au mois d'avril mais en fait
pour soutenir les étudiants confiné qui
pour certains ont des difficultés depuis
le confinement du fait qu'il n'est plus
leur job étudiant ou qui n'ont pas
forcément la possibilité de retourner
chez leur famille les retours qu'on a
c'est que les étudiants
ça leur fait de faire un petit show
fédère d'avoir rêve c'était de la même
ponctuelle mais c'est leur permet de
pouvoir subvenir à nîmes à leurs besoins
et d'apporter une aide dans la dans leur
situation un peu précaire actuellement
160 étudiants sont aidés actuellement
par le secours populaire des abymes
pendant cette période du confinement
sont 77 avaient pu en bénéficier
lors du premier au printemps dernier
avec la crise sanitaire d'ailleurs
certains étudiants se retrouvent seuls
et pour les étrangers pas de possibilité
de rentrer chez eux c'est le cas de yann
heures david étudiant colombien en
géographie à l'université versailles à
saint quentin en yvelines une rencontre
dans le cadre de notre série de
portraits que nous vous proposons cette
semaine sur tv 60,18 ce portrait signé
ce soir par astrid bergère malgré la
crise sanitaire certains étudiants être
j'ai poursuivre leur cursus en france
c'est le cas de ce colombien de 28 ans
il fait des études de géographie et
d'aménagement du territoire depuis trois
ans on a commencé assez intéressante et
j'ai très très super que les professeurs
qui nous donne des courses on désespère
qu'en général en la matière qu'il donne
il donne des conférences
ils font des recherches aussi en même
temps donc ça fait une espèce d
inspiration pour moi et je pense aussi
pour l'école mes camarades il travaille
dans une grande chaîne de restauration
rapide en plus de ses études
mais avec la crise sanitaire il fait
moins d'heures ponctuellement il aidé
par le crous lors de fortes difficultés
financières le plus dur a été pendant le
premier confinement ont déprimé
confirmant cette année -2 pour moi est
la question des financiers parce que
comme j'avais échangé longuement parce
que rien ici pas pas beaucoup et c'est
aussi à nous instruire donc c'était
compliqué mais vraiment compliqué
pendant des mois mais après
moralement il a réussi à surmonter cette
période difficile en se plongeant au
maximum dans les études j'ai vraiment
profité ces temps pour étudier quand je
travaillais pas être tous a profité pour
monter mon dossier n'est aussi il n'a
pas vu sa famille depuis plusieurs
années c'est par internet qu'ils peuvent
se parler
la solitude parfois pesante en fait j'ai
passé 24 les tremper à raymond seul donc
c'était un peu une façon vieux continent
et communiquer avec eux quelques façons
j'appelle ma mère j'ai colombie pour
savoir comment le voir mais je m'en sors
mon frère et même apc rappelle-t-on la
famille aujourd'hui il a de nombreux
amis en france
avant la crise il s'y retrouver tous les
samedis pour faire du foot et partager
un repas
maintenant c'est par visioconférence
qu'il se voit ces journées sont
désormais rythmée par les cours à
distance et les promenade avec son chien
en attendant un retour à la normale
avant de refermer ce journal du sport et
la carte quasi définitive des jo de 2024
de paris connue elle a été présenté ce
mercredi au bureau du comité
d'organisation
selon les informations de plusieurs de
nos confrères dont l'équipe l'ensemble
des sites siby noah et confirmés dont le
château de versailles pour
l'organisation des épreuves d'équitation
le site de la mode b
on dans le loir et cher étaient évoqués
en potentiel concurrent pour le reste le
golf au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines vous voyez le bmx bmx reis à
lille de loisirs le vtt sur la colline
de l'encours et le cyclisme sur piste au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines enceinte
saint-quentinoise devrait accueillir
aussi les scream dans le cadre de
l'épreuve de pentathlon moderne car tu
décides figé et valider définitivement
le 17 décembre prochain par le conseil
d'administration
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]